gonna live in Japan for a year you can
see PewDiePie up there exactly yeah what
do you like about Japan it's like spot
in Tokyo it's called Golden guy it's a
collection of 100 tiny bars and each bar
only says like five people you're like
in an intimate situation with your
bartender and anyone else in there like
you have to talk to them what if you
don't speak Japanese yeah that's pretty
easy right there's like super nice
people who will like teach you a little
Japanese and you'll teach them a little
English but Google translate you like
meet both ways really yeah I had a
bartender she pulled out Google
translate and I pulled out Google
translate and I was like a [__] yeah